dans quelle mesure pensez-vous être le
candidat idéal pour ce poste
j'ai exercé des tâches similaires dans
mes emplois précédents
ah oui donc de taille points surtout
d'accord très bien et est ce que vous
considérez comme quelqu'un d'autonome et
quels sont vos rapports avec la
hiérarchie
bon vous saigner du nez
ils m'angoisse lui
ça va mieux
le des bonbons à l'est alors quels sont
vos points forts la rigueur la ténacité
très bien oui mais encore la minus la
minutie à tien shan psychopathe qui
n'est jamais des yeux
[ __ ] qui n'est pas des yeux quoi où ça
se trouve il cligne des yeux quand je
cligne des yeux du coup je vois pas qui
clignent des yeux
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya coiffeuse france
est malade
ces retards et évite son regard non
soutient son regard oui
vas-y montre lui aussi était en sait
quelque chose dans l'oeil non j'ai un
gouffre comme temps à ça non non ça
c'est moi c'est de ces jeux comme ça bah
ouais moi aussi je suis un psychopathe
records [ __ ] mais il s'en fout
royalement
ça c'est le genre de mec qui pète les
plombs d'un coup il ya un [ __ ] ils
bougent facile c'est ton territoire
c'est toi le patron c'est toi qui as
l'ascendant tu le déstabilise vos points
faibles
quels sont vos points faibles le social
le social ça alors il va buter pourquoi
je suis franc [ __ ] mais moi aussi je
peux le but est bâtard ok faut que je
bouge
la meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué ça
ne c'est pas dur député quelqu'un quand
il n'ya pas l'affect je connais même pas
on s'en fout de lui c'est son fils y
meurt d'accord que ce paragraphe pouvoir
sur la tête non bon prix tir il est quoi
tu sais bien sa part dans la nuque
honnêtement je pense à lui après moi
mais avec quelle formation et leurs
proches
ok c'est parti sébastien les gars tu
spaf dans les yeux qui piquent sa petite
fille qui s'applique cette épouse à la
tête dont les punaises matin arrêtons de
regarder comme ça des gens vivent des
gens de gens à l'italie oui oui à
lédenon pas bonjour alice appelle la
sécurité il n'y a pas de sécurité
oui oui oui oui ça exactement
oui oh non mais que tu es comme c'est
pas possible
mais moi je veux pas mourir ici dans ce
bureau de merde cha cha cha le tien
capsule bureau où il est oui c'est
pourquoi il n'est pas là c'est pas vrai
mais il y eut chuté à mon câble au nord
moi je veux pas mourir étranglée par un
câble ethernet
enfin deux trois ans
[Musique]